a ea minha cueca já a a deixa te viu
quem te vê
em 2000 o lado de sua aqui quem fala é o
lugar que seja muito bem vindo já mais
um vídeo e um estrado de que com ele
tevez dois deles chega equipada que os
jogos foi desenhar pedir me quer pelos
de lá que vocês têm história então pega
uma chave abre o cofre igual passar um
jogo está a ficar mais simples bora lá
então já pessoal tons por experimentar
vocês já sabem que eu adoro estas coisas
confluem de tevez e e fluindo e assim
meu deus posso customizar o meu time eu
vou escolher os fãs de tango e talvez o
rosinha por trás é a sala em que está
aqui com larga é sempre me convence
gostei que o acostumado com batman nos
jogos já não sai
nós temos aqui vários mapas 1 mapas que
supostamente existe a noção de thames
pela webcam evoca este parece na última
pessoa objectivo deste jogo é bastante
simples nós apenas temos de encontrar é
desta tarde para conseguir sair daqui
com vida não é porque vão andar monstros
atrás nós e nós temos que conseguir
encontrar a start ou uma tarde o que já
temos duas faltas 18 e eles vão começar
a andar ea sopa né
op por lesto a jesus a ea minha cueca já
tá até mim eu já ouvi eu ainda bem que
eu tenho facilidade rock-cordel caraças
será que eu moro aqui na escola estourou
assim eu não consegue passar aqui ok tá
segurando o rei concorda que morreu eu
que já temos em nosso estado e outra vez
faltou 8 vamos lá tentar apanhar as
tardes em que osmar ela apareça aqui o
outro ataque outra que é tão boa dora
conectar o eu consiga pagar o flash led
toca e seleccionou plantar flash lite
pra ela não consegue ver não sabemos
temos que experimentar né jovem mais uma
está a ser fácil até já o fim de seu
mandato ele foge do que o esperado
o filho da mãe meu estilo é difícil
agora vou escolher agora outro mapa
talvez um assim mais ã o
olha quem tá aqui eo zé da faca vamos
pra eles temos num armazém com muitas
caixinhas amiguinhos hoje a uma torta
sério eu ouvi que qualquer coisa vocês
já ouviram isto porque aquilo e aquilo
por si um olho mas não aquelas coisas
que mede a temperatura e buscando sair
alguém talento tabata qualquer coisa
ayew bom é o pão hotel afirma josé da
faca o mesmo tempo em que o grito é
muito está muito alto com descontos com
desconto a que não assistimos com ele
ainda vai atrás de mim ainda meu
deputado que voltar para trás da nato
também às vezes parece que o burro a
estão laboratório sozinho e experiências
por mandar as pessoas postura já temos
quase já tive aqui né
já tive que oi o que é que este sangue
no quadro vai dar a tua manhã e outra à
tarde vamos pegar isso o que eu sabia
que auxiliam câmeras para ver eu sabia
forte da força
a outra estátua finais não sei pra onde
é construído por livre mas sangue
embaixo que andaram a fazer aqui que as
pessoas meu e vou continuar atira te
encontrar aqui alguma coisa melhor pra
minha câmera ficou sem bateria o que vai
morrer por isso explica um salto no mais
badalado escolher outro mapa agora os
prós com ela aqui no df daquilo que é um
software que os canais onde fechou
durante meu deus uma tarde outra já
começamos com uma fala de novo que eu
sei fazer contas 10 - um novo isso não
parece ser uma escola mas tudo bem o
neto am df daquilo que não seria titular
mas percebo o stf
eu sou teu amigo é do sul deteve o uso
bonito bem a gente tem uma sala de aula
o ataque
meu deus meu deus jogou por uma tarde
boa hora e isso é vai né não o chefe
ainda como filho da mãe
o sangue vem da cama alguém morreu nesta
cama e outra vez menos sério como é que
é possível ser este o grupo é difícil
tem que ter muita atenção porque quando
tinha aparece perto de mim começar
aquela musiquinha ela já tem certa
parece estar tudo calmo agora anda
porque estou vivo eu consigo sentir o
cheiro demônio é opinião que mil canadá
susto erro
bicho do inferno não merece judas foi
infectada por alguma razão outro ataque
ok ok é fator de duas torres 43 costa
passar isso lá para tutor de dubai
ai ai eu estava por vir do chefe porque
o fizestes só faltava do istat meu vamos
tentar outro mapa satélite jogos ganhei
custar do jec celso roth smid a nokia
banestes escala extra o w filhos caldas
mas alguma coisa que ensina não
conseguiu passar de escadas que não
servem pra nada agora o que encontramos
a nossa primeira tarde se este mapa
maior quer dizer que nós temos mais
possibilidades de fuga mas também temos
mais monstros atrás não se eu fizesse um
jogo é assim que faria o show que não
estão em uma tarde julgada porque me
parece que um quadrado o demônio deste
mapa não deixe sangue ou de chocó
espalhado no mapa a partir da segunda
parte que nós apanhamos começam a
perceber a cair temos sete isso vai
ficar atentos agora vai vai
tudo e qualquer coisa lei que é aquilo a
aam eu tava vendo transmita uma faca em
poiares joga no chão vamos embora vamos
embora em faltar aqui por cima o meu
deus o meu ver o tal lhe ama a europa
league mas com a shell não chega nada
vai imposto você qual é óbvio que cheira
mal né
tal é mais uma a cair vamos lá duas
tarde ou faltou eu fosse foi nem treinar
entre viajar os long term branco
costelas fora o que falta nos rouba tal
túnel indicando a [ __ ] da tafona cada
fato uma só falta uma das questões que
encontrarão essa coisa não é porque tem
que também traz bem não não se entrega
que não consegue apanhar né
aí vamos esperar que ela pois não não
não faltou em suma uma não espero uma
tarde faltava um disco de rock vamos
experimentar o mapa novo estou a luz
dreaming ou seja quem vai andar atrás de
mim é o ala estamos num sonho da aula o
que parece fácil os apanhámos do start
estão ilumina isso não ilumina que
escuridão esta manter não funciona
direito não sei se foi por aqui mas
vamos lá para cima porque lá em cima
estamos mais perto de jesus e jesus
protestos às vezes não têm tanta treta
não estão é o sonique bar com alguém
chorar aqui em cima alan shore enquanto
sonha mais uma tarde ok vamos fazer
por isso só sei lá você escuta casos
passou lhe apareceu num bonito por seu
lado que tem voz do homem é preso que
está a vida é um homem à comissão nem
jogar uma tarde uma tarde ou tratar com
carinho meu parceiro porque essas
alturas nome sempre comissionistas ela
transporta som tela na num site ai ai ai
eu vi no fim não não não supostamente o
alerta amarelo porque tu és um demônio
preta lá atrás me pela sombra eu só
quero estar de ir embora daqui nem vou
ser eu não penso em mais nada lá eu
quero sou matar não duas facções duas é
porque algo boa matar matar toca
faltando uma pessoa luma uma tarde meu
deus é isso que eu vou conseguir passar
nada lá aí ela vai apanhar agora ela vai
lá está muito perto de corre corre
encontrei me encontrei em contra-ataque
tarde desta especial e é isso que nós
vamos chegar porque com isto espero que
vocês tenham gostado se a favor pessoal
enquanto com a flec favorito e no
esquema estar diante para lá